Here are the best ways to land a quality man
in the year 2024.
If you hope to marry a quality man,
you need to find one who is masculine.
And if you want a masculine man,
you need to be a feminine woman.
In a world where women are taught to be loud
and severe and harsh,
it can be very difficult to unlearn those traits.
But the beautiful thing about femininity
is that it is in all of us.
If you are a female,
it is in your blood.
You just need to shut off those layers
that the world has put on you.
And if you can pull it off,
and if you can become a little bit softer
and more nurturing,
and really value and prioritize those things,
you will stand out.
The second thing is to expand your social circles.
I think a lot of us mistaken having high standards
with just being snooty and avoiding people.
And I promise,
if you walk around putting off that kind of energy,
you are not going to find
the man that you were looking for.
You can have high standards up here.
You need to treat everybody with respect.
You need to go out of your way to get to know people,
because they are worth getting to know,
even if you don't wanna necessarily date them.
Becoming friends with people,
people you see at the gym everyday,
people you see at the grocery store.
Getting to Know their names and who they are
will make you a better person
and will give you more opportunities
to meet the kind of man that you want to meet.
A lot of times,
we also make the mistake of thinking
that god is just going to bring someone right to us,
right to our front door.
I found that he usually doesn't work that way.
He usually nudges you to go
get out of your comfort zone
and go put yourself out there
and be available
and be open to his blessings.
And that brings me to my third point,
which is to involve god.
And I'm not just talking to those of you
who are super religious.
I'm talking to anyone.
God is available for anyone.
No matter what you claim to believe,
no matter how good you are at going to church
or whatever,
he's there, and he will listen to you
and he will guide you.
And that's the wonderful thing about him
is that you do not need to have any prerequisites.
You do not need to be any type of way to get his help.
Talk to him
and tell him about the kind of man you hope to find.
Tell him about your struggles
and how difficult it feels.
Tell him all of these things.
And while you're at it,
pray for that guy who's out there.
Pray for your future husband,
who you believe you will find,
because he is out there.
Somewhere right now.
Living life,
going day to day,
struggling, learning
all those things.
And I think praying for him
is one of the greatest things you can do.